Bán nhân dân tình cầu bằng bán hành công biển hoa tóc số 2 sau ngày 1 vài tháng 3
Cây việc cần chương trình khai tất cả biển thác ứng phó với mưa lớn, đủ ông, luquet sản ở đất
Không địa yêu cầu các địa phương kinh thích dời người dân khỏi của người không bảo đam an toàn
khi có người cơ sảy ra luquet sản ở đất, gập sâu, đặc biệt liwi người dạ, chẻ em, người quyết tật và các đối thượng yêu thế
Vìa xưa tán phải được thực hiện chủ đầu, không chờ sảy ra sự cố mỗi tổ chức trí chuyển
Vì bán nhân dân tình hành hoa bằng công biển số khu ba, yêu cầu các sở bằng ngành đơn vị cóp tình
Vì bán nhân dân các sảy phường và các đơn vị liên quan tập trung theo dõi, chú đống trên khai các biển thác ứng phó với đật mưa lớn, từ đây mùi bài tháng 3 đến 2 muu tháng 3
Mục biêu đặt lên hàng đầu là bảo đam an toàn tính mạnh nhất dân, đúng thời gian chử thiệt hại về tài sản của nhà nước và người dân
Mọi giá các tỉnh đến mùi tiếvac, lòng kai, tí thỏ, thánh huyen, đá khi khóa tự ngán giá sóa các khu vực dân kư ở vèn sau, sối, khu vực chứng thấp có người cơ sảy ra ngập lú sau, lũ quét, sản lần đất để chủ động sự tán người dân
Chức đó trong tối mẹ bài tháng 3 đến 3 ngày mẹ tháng 3 tháng 3, nhiều khu vực vực vực mùi chung dụ bắt bộ đã suy hiện mưa bơ mưa tò và rông
Còn người mưa rất tò mùi số điểm, viên nhận lượng mơ lớn như Trung tâm một tính lào kai, một chăm năm ba phải tháng 1 lê mẹ,
Cầm khế phút thỏ một chăm bằng bà phải bốn mê mẹ, thịt vận cao bằng một chăm phải bốn mê mẹ và cũng chìu thành miệng tâm 1 lê mẹ, tháng 2 bảo của chúng tâm dự bảo khi tượng thịt văn cuốc gia,
Tư chiều tối nay đến hết ngày mê chiến tháng 3, bắt bộ và khu vực thành hoa đến mắt khoảng chiếc tức tục có mưa bơ mưa tò và rông,
lượng mưa quẩu biến từ bệ mưa để một chăm sống mùi mê mê mẹ, cù bộ có nơi trên 2 chăm năm mê mê mê.
Bù mưa lớn sẽ tập chung ngọt khu vực bắt bộ và thân hả đến mắt khoảng chiếc, với thời gian mưa sẽ tập chung vào chiều và đêm,
sang ngày hai mưa và ngày hai mốt tháng tâm, thì bộ mưa lớn ngày sẽ gạm ở khu vực bùng lũi và dịch truyền xuống phía Nam,
còn tập chung là có tỉ trong mặt bộ, nhiều hơn ngọt khu vực thân hả, nghệ âm, hả dính, mắt khoảng chiếc,
tổng lượng ngưa của cả đợt, tính từ nay mùi mề bệ tấn tâm đến hết ngày hai mốt tháng tâm,
có tính lai châu, định biến mắt tương quang, cao bằng lạm sương, phổ biến từ 1 chăm đến 2 chăm mê mê.
Chân đợt, cuộc bộ có nơi trên 3 chăm mê mê trên đợt, còn có tính, cơ tháng phố còn lại của vực bộ và hút vực tương tháng hả đến mắt khoảng chiếc,
sẽ phổ biến khoảng từ 1 chăm năm mưa đến 3 chăm mê trên đợt, cuộc bộ có nơi trên 4 chăm năm mê mê.
Chân đợt, cạnh máo mì cơm gưa có cụng độ lưỡn trên 1 chăm mê mê trên đợt.
Mưa lưỡn có hả năng gây ra tính trạng gập cũng tại các phủng chung thấp, các khu đồ thị,
công nghiệp luộ qua chân các phủng xong sử nhỏ, thật lợt, các xương đợt.
Bởi lượng bước kéo dài nhiều ngày, đặc biệt tại khu vực bụi và chung dô,
khu vực có sả giá luộ qua trả nở đất có thể ra tăng, khá đợt, kênh chủ động ra soát những khu vực cóng vi cơ cao.
Nhất là các liêm có dân cư năm mê văn xong sối, giới trên tà luy hoặc tại các khu vực biển dốc.